おはよーございます
はじめしゃちょーです
あーーーー
はい
というわけで完全に寝起きでございます
おはようございますおはようございます
おはようございます
あの、僕みたいに口を開けて寝るようなタイプの人間は
起きた時に非常に口の中が
なぜかというとそう
口を開けて寝るから
起きた時にはこうなんか口の中が
乾燥してベロッベロしてるんすよ、うがいしよ
起きた時に
めちゃくちゃ口の中がﾊﾟﾗﾗﾗってなってるわけなんですよ
でそのﾊﾟﾗﾗﾗってなってる口をどうするかっていうと
歯磨き、うがい
いろんな手があるんですけども
これに限る、と思っています
あんましないんだけどね
マウスウォッシュやったことはあるんですけども
やるとほぼ確実に口の中が痛くなるんですよ
こういうリステニンとか
ガム
モンダミン
やすそうなマウスウォッシュとかもありますね
他にもこういろんな色があるんですけども
マウスウォッシュについて総じて言えることは全部
マウスウォッシュ一回すると
口がすごい痛くないですか？
ﾋﾟﾘﾋﾟﾘﾋﾟﾘﾋﾟﾘ
口がこうやってる時点ですごく痛いので
なかなか長い時間やったことはないんですけどもー
やっぱこれ聞くんですけども
なかなか効果があるみたいで
虫歯予防とかにも凄いいいらしいです
というわけで！
もしこの苦手なマウスウォッシュを１００回続けてやると
口の中にどのような変化があるのか
今回実験していきたいと思います
ひょっとしたら１００回連続でやると
ものすごい歯が強くなって
歯が永続的に虫歯にならない
コーティング状の歯になるかもしれないんで
あとはそれに
ではいこう
ほんとにさマウスウォッシュってなにが嫌っかって
痛いんすよね、とりあえず
乾杯
ん‘‘ん‘‘ん‘‘
ぶえっ
はぁっはぁっはぁっはぁっはぁっ
うぇぇ
ほんと痛いんすよ
なんかこのほっぺのここらへんとか凄い痛くなってきて
あーこれあと99回するのか
舌も痛いしここもなんか凄い
まあきれいになるからいいんですけどね
２回目いきます
え、あこれ99回もするの？
ぶえっ
はぁっはぁっはっ
ん‘‘ん‘‘ん‘‘ん‘‘
４回目
ぶえっ
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
みずみずみずみず
あ、やばいやばい
口い痛い口が痛い口が痛い
５回目
ぶぐえぇ
ぶぇぇぇ
ぅぅぅぅうぇぇ
俺これ100回いけんのかな
うわあっあはっは痛い
やったことある人ならわかると思うんですけど
極度に痺れる
ちょっと10回交代でやってきます
どぅへっ
ううっ
(キラーン音)
あ‘‘っはっは
10回目だ
ぷっぷぇっ
はい、10回目できました
あ、あの10回して感じるんですけども
歯がつるつるしてきてて
なんていうか舌の感覚がねえやな
もう舌が完全に麻痺してます
で口ん中も痛いです
11回目からはちょっと変えます
ぶわああ
うわあぁ
あああああああ‘‘－！！あ‘‘！！
痛い！ああ‘‘あ‘‘あ‘‘あ‘‘ー！あー！痛いよ
ほんとにまじむりもーむりもーむり
あー！痛い！
まって
もーこー色からしてこれ絶対強いやつじゃん
うう‘‘っ
ぶはっ
ははははははははははｈははっはっは
あ‘‘！あ！あ！－あ‘‘－！！
うわあ！まず！
うえぇ
あ‘‘あ‘‘あ‘‘あ‘‘
あー！むりむり
はいえー30回いきました
これだめだもうこれが強いんだな
殺菌力が最強みたいな感じっぽいっすね
もう多分結構今のでもってかれた
こういうなんか安っぽそうなやつが1番やりやすいのかと思います
31回目
うん
やさしかったなあ
こっちは完全に..ああ‘‘でも痛いよ
やっぱ痛いもんは痛いな
ちょっともうスピードでいくわもうここまで来ると
41回目いきます
41回目です
んん？
後から来るやつだぁ
ああ、まって無理
ああうあ‘‘あ‘‘うええ
感覚が無いんだよ口の中
たぶん今
天の声：50回
天：あーいいねいいね
なんかこれこそＴＨＥシンプルみたいなとこあるなモンダミンだ
マウスウォッシュを50回超えると
はじめの口の中は
痛覚を忘れた
天：はいよいよい
天：60
はあはあはっ
よしいくぜラストスパートだ
天：飲んで飲んでゆすいでゆすいで
天：うーーんいいねいいねｗｗｗ
天：73ｗｗ
えぇうえぇえ
おーおー
あー！あー！
うえぇぇ
ああぁぁあなんでなんだぁ
あぁあぁああ
はあっぁ！あぁうえぇ
というわけでラスト
100回でした
あざー
やってみて思ったんですけど
ラスト！
ENDING♪
いやほんダメだわ
ほんっとにマネしないでねこれほんとに
あのやったあとも口の中今ピリピリしてるし
唇も見ての通り腫れております
ただ
めちゃくちゃ息はキレイだぜ